okay well good afternoon and welcome to
today's lecture and to this event in the
Frankie program sponsored by the Frankie
program in science and Humanities today
we're going to be hearing the first of
lectures this spring in a continuation
in a series of lectures on biology
individuality in the humanities and so
in this fall we focused more on
neurobiology and the the challenges of
explanations of consciousness and and
functions neural functions and in the
spring will be focusing more on
evolutionary biology and this series of
lectures has been sponsored by a a
collaboration a rebel action whatever
you want to call it between myself and
and Bob Shulman which has been a real
pleasure to to organize today we're
going to have a lecture by professor
alan love who is an associate professor
of philosophy of science at the
University of Minnesota he has his
Bachelor on science from MIT and a PhD
in history and philosophy of science at
the University of Pittsburgh he did his
dissertation on explanations of the
evolution of novelty and is published
extensively in the areas of novelty
developmental biology hierarchy and
causation homology and function and
competing levels of explanation and
biology and most recently focusing in on
genetics environment development and the
like he is also at the at the Minnesota
Center for the philosophy of science
where he'll be taking over I understand
in July as the new director of that of
that Institute and a definitely national
leader in this field so today he's going
to be talking about integrating generic
and genetic explanations of biological
phenomena of welcome to welcome to you
and thank you for coming it's a real
delight to be here I wanted to begin
with a brief remark on the frankie
program because the language online i
think was quite striking for me in terms
of
aims to foster communication mutual
understanding collaborative research and
teaching among diverse scientific and
human humanistic disciplines that's
really goals shared by the Minnesota
Center for philosophy of science and
definitely is something that we're
trying to engage in as well and that the
program was founded on the twin
convictions that the fundamental
questions that engage humanists must be
informed by basic insights of science
and that meaningful scientific inquiry
depends on humanistic knowledge and I at
least imagine that that reciprocity is
the primary platform for my own work one
of the things that I've tried to do
throughout my research from graduate
school to the present is is find that
reciprocal interaction between sciences
and the humanities so let me begin the
story today with somebody that may be
familiar to some of you John trinkaus
commonly known as Trank a Yale
embryologist from the years 48 288 were
the forint with a formal time he retired
and then passed away in 2003 and why
he's important for the start of the
story is this book that he wrote cells
into organs the forces that shape the
embryo the first edition came out in 69
the second in 84 and this book
articulated in a way that a lot of
people in the community really
appreciated an explanatory approach to
development that combined a variety of
different factors and yet tranq himself
acknowledged in the preface that some
will find that there is rather less
emphasis in this book on research at the
molecular level than they might desire
and this kit was in the second edition
preface and part of what he was reacting
to was the fact that molecular genetic
methods had been exploding and coming
online for a lot of the developmental
biology community and in that we see
what he really wanted was this robust
multi angled approach to development the
theme of this
book is how the behavior of cells their
motility their contractility the
adhesiveness of their surface and their
physical and chemical properties
determinants create the anatomical
structure of the individual and then he
got a little feisty and I don't think
that anybody who knew trink would be
surprised that he got feisty but that's
for another talk it is well to be
reminded that molecular does not
necessarily mean analytical nor by
contrast a sailor histological
necessarily imply descriptive sound
descriptive and analytical studies are
obviously required at both and all
levels of organization snobbish
references to certain morphological
studies as merely descriptive only
served to reveal the naivete of the
authors and if insisted upon could
impede advance of the field after all
running a gel is also descriptive but no
one questions its utility as a means of
learning what molecules are there so by
analytical drink has in mind here causal
analysis experimental analysis we might
not use that same terminology today so
he clearly is feeling some kind of
pressure that he's articulating in this
comment about the approaches that he's
giving in the cells into Oregon's book
as being criticized along these lines
now interestingly one of his PhD
students Albert Harris one of the best
he'd ever had according to shrink was
interested in following out this
research program this is from a letter
that Albert wrote to drink in 85 one of
the things I'm most interested in
modeling is the limb bud and the
mechanical relations between the
elasticity and our contractility of the
ectoderm to the shaping of the bud more
or less after the fashion of a balloon
my main working assumption is that the
peculiar shape of the cells of the
apical Ridge results from some peculiar
mechanical properties and that this is
the key to the shaping of the whole bud
now Harris was not alone in this a
number of people at this time were
pursuing similar sorts of projects what
was interesting is the way Harris was
bumping up against resistance and so
about ten years later in another letter
this is what he says to trink I was
infuriated by the tunnel vision of the
molecular types
they are just so blind to mechanics they
see things their way and only their way
and the flood of solid data their
techniques is producing reinforces and
validates their narrowness so you can't
argue with them to the molecular types
it causes a molecule or a gene to
explain a phenomenon is to identify
genes and characterize proteins without
which the phenomena will fail or be
abnormal a molecule as an explanation of
force is a description to argue
otherwise brings pity at best and so
here I think you get encapsulated this
idea that it's not just that an
alternate explanatory project is taken
to be not so interesting but literally
irrelevant from the perspective of
somebody who's trying to work in it and
in fact this kind of warning was raised
many years ago by Darcy Thompson who at
the beginnings of the development of
genetics was worried about this
possibility occurring he said it's an
exaggeration if we tend to neglect these
direct physical and mechanical modes of
causation altogether and to see in the
characters merely the results of
variation and of heredity now the
situation at the time that Harris was
writing was one where that had been
forgotten and in fact this was the
settled attitude and nih proposal review
from the mid-1990s captured it
succinctly the physics of how embryos
change shape is neither and important
nor an interesting question and so you
can sort of see the kind of attitude
that Harris was up against now if that
was where our story ended that would not
be so exciting but of course we've had a
reversal of fortune over the past 20
years or so here signaled in this paper
from nature which is modeled
specifically on Darcy Thompson on the
growth and form of the gut trying to
explain the shape properties of the gut
through mechanical principles as well as
review articles such as this the
interplay between cell signaling and
mechanics and developmental processes we
to reviews the spate of work that has
been done at this intersection over the
past several years now what's striking
to me as a philosopher interested in the
reasoning in the sciences especially
biology is this worry here about the
long-term challenges in integrating
biomechanics with genetic analysis of
developing embryos I take that to be the
challenge of integration so when the
scientists working in this domain are
articulating what the aim is the
language is the language of integration
the field needs increased integration
between cell biology cell mechanics and
biomechanical analyses integrating
biomechanics with genetic analysis of
developing embryos more complete
integrated views of developmental
mechanics that will provide lasting
insights in the development and the
self-organizing processes that assemble
organs and lay the foundation for
physiological function so I'm broadly
labeling this project explanatory
integration combining or synthesizing
different types of causal explanations
or different kinds of causal factors
into a more unified formulation which
hopefully the point is to yield an
increased understanding of complex
phenomena that result from a plurality
of causes what's striking and
interesting to me about this is it also
is oftentimes interdisciplinary because
the kinds of causes that are treated in
different disciplines differ and so it
actually forces they're coming together
in order to accomplish these types of
projects so here's what I want to do I
want to sort of lay out a little bit of
the playing field of the interplay of
causes of the integration of causal
explanation so you can sort of see what
at least I think I'm seeing at this
point in the science then I want to
bring in a discussion about the
composition of causes and into your
mixture of effects which comes out of
the work of John Stuart Mill and I think
helps diagnose some of what's going on
here then I want to look at that problem
that's diagnosed namely the intermixture
of effects and ask how current
philosophical models
integration handle that and as you might
not be too surprised to hear i will say
that they don't and so i will then turn
to try and offer my own perspective and
for temporal sequence juxtaposition
actual difference makers unpack the
meaning of that when i get there and
then I want to end with a little
discussion of the consequences of this
approach to explanatory integration in
particular a trade-off that exists
between integration and generality so
let me start with the interplay of
causes in the integration of causal
explanations throughout I want to use
this terminology so I'm just going to
put it up front when I talk about a
generic explanation I mean a causal
explanation that appeals to for example
mechanical forces due to geometric
arrangements of musa scale materials or
abstract properties of network
organisation the explanation is generic
because they can apply to living and
nonliving phenomena okay in the sense of
where those properties obtain a genetic
explanation as i'm calling it here is a
causal explanation that appeals to
changes in the frequency distribution or
expression of genes and interactions
among their RNA and protein products the
explanation is specific to living
phenomena which exhibit these genetic
properties and then the main biological
phenomena that i want to consider is the
variety of interacting processes that
generate the heterogeneous shapes sizes
and structural features of an organism
as it develops so this kind of analysis
can be applied to other biological
phenomena and a engaged in a project
right now where we're looking at other
areas as well and some areas in
evolutionary biology but today i'm just
going to focus on development so genetic
explanatory approaches are predominant
in biology and for good reasons the
empirical successes of experimental
methodologies and molecular cell and
developmental biology or major
achievements and genetic explanations
exhibit the virtue of specificity in the
sense that you can specifically
intervene and identify the factors that
are making
difference as Frazier in Holland have
described as a molecular metamorphosis
of our understanding of embryology as we
let on the identification of genes that
control development this can be stated
in a very strong fashion and here is one
way of doing it from Eric Davidson
elements of the genome contain a
sequence specific code for development
and they determine the particular
outcome the developmental processes and
thus the form of the animal produced by
every embryo and then this is my
highlight development is the execution
of the genetic program for construction
of given species of organism and so I
think that in the midst of discussion
about genetic approaches this is
probably one of the stronger
formulations but one that at least
clearly has basis in the success of
those research programs over the past
several decades at the same time there
has been an ascendancy of generic
approaches increasing attention to how
physical processes can explain
biological phenomena appeals to generic
features that are not unique to
biological entities and in fact a
something that biology some biologists
have recognized was missing so this is a
quote from mold or 2008 the current
preeminence of the molecular genetic
approach to biology in which living
systems are conceptualized as networks
of interacting genes and proteins may
have obscured this inevitable link
between physics and biology and the mind
of scientists of course it was never the
case that people were going to deny that
organisms were somehow subject to the
laws or principles of physics but the
idea is to go back to that earlier quote
encapsulated from the NIH proposal
review that though embryos are subject
to physics the physics of embryos is an
uninteresting question and not worth
pursuing and so what we get in the
literature over the past decade or so is
a lot of attention and similar language
where this idea of interplay is brought
up between biomechanics and gene
expression
so just give you a few examples creasing
number point to the existence of
reciprocal interplay between expression
of some developmental genes and the
mechanical forces that are associated
with morfa genetic movements both the
physics and bio chemical signaling
pathways of the embryo contribute to the
form of the organism notice how that's
actually in direct contradiction to the
Davidson quote about what development is
and then we're entering an exciting time
when interdisciplinary research enables
us to understand the fundamental
properties of tissue function almost
stasis and morphogenesis by considering
the interplay between bio chemical and
mechanical signals across different
scales of organization within that going
back to that earlier article that I
highlighted is that call to effect a
kind of combination there's been a
renewed appreciation of the fact that to
understand morphogenesis in three
dimensions it's necessary to combine
molecular insights jeans and morphogens
with knowledge of physical processes
transport deformation and flow generated
by growing tissues so I label this the
integrative expectation experimental
biologists involved here aim to
integrate genetic and generic causes
into explanations of the origin of
morphological form and ontogeny and a
reduction of one to the other is not
tenable from the vantage point of
biological practice now that doesn't
mean that it's obvious how the two go
together and in fact one of the problems
and you see this in that presentation in
the on the growth and form of the gut
paper is it actually doesn't accomplish
the combining it just gives you one
mechanical approach and actually doesn't
treat the genetic components so there's
lots of studies that have one of the
other and the question is how do those
get brought together and not just set
side by side well part of the reason why
you don't see it more regulators
integration is not easy for one thing
the models that are used or not commence
herbal the model systems where molecular
and cellular manipulations are simplest
are some of the most challenging to
measure absolute forces are mature
properties by contrast model systems
where tissue scale forces of material
properties can be directly measure the
most challenging to manipulate
genetically there's also dis analogies
between the experimental manipulations
one of the greatest challenges to
understanding the role mechanics and
development is that the physics of
mechanical structures can't be knocked
out in the same sense as individual
genes can be mutated in addition to
these difficulties sometimes the
explanations are in competition with
each other so from a recent article in
science crocodilians head scales are not
genetically controlled developmental
units their spatial patterning is
generated through physical cracking of a
living tissue in a stress field so
you're not going to try and combine them
if you think that they are mutually
exclusive or somehow competing and so
that provides another sort of challenge
for this type of project so if we just
briefly dwell on this example I wanted
to pull out a few more quotes from this
paper this is some of the figures from
the paper illustrating the difference
between the reptilian head scales which
are genetically controlled from those of
the crocodile we've shown that the
irregular polygonal domains of skin on
the crocodile face and jaws are produced
by cracking a mechanism that is distinct
from those generating scales on the post
cranial portion of the crocodile body as
well as on the body and head of all of
the reptiles so here we have that these
are competing explanations one of them
is right one of them is not the cracking
process is primarily physical and now we
start to see that even in this case
where the situation is one of
competition all of a sudden the language
of combining comes back however it does
not mean that genetically controlled
parameters are irrelevant for example
although a crack pattern is visible in
all crocodilian species spatial
distribution varies considerably
possibly because of species-specific
skull geometry and growth but also skin
composition and thickness and wait for
it but there's that word again interplay
given that these parameters as well as
cell proliferation or genetically
controlled the variation of head crack
patterns among crocodilian species is
likely due to an interplay between
physically and genetically controlled
parameters and
now we sound like we're back again to
trying to figure out how we can put them
together so that was just a way of
quickly trying to survey the landscape
of the area of biology that I'm looking
at now I want to try and say a little
bit about what this situation poses as a
dilemma in terms of combining or
offering explanatory integration and I
want to do that by looking at the work
of John Stuart Mill and after his famous
discussion of the four methods of
observation experimental inquiry he
raised a concern about the applicability
of these methods to complex causal
relationships and this is what he said
it's been necessary to suppose for the
sake of simplification that this
analytical operation is encumbered by no
other difficulties than what are
essentially inherent in its nature and
to represent to ourselves there for
every effect on the one hand as
connected exclusively with a single
cause and on the other hand is incapable
of being mixed and confounded with
another coexistent effect so what we
have here is to idealization zeeeee that
have been made in the articulation of
these methods one of them can be labeled
one cause one affect the other no mixing
of effects and so here are those
explicit idealizations mill calls the
first one the plurality of causes it
primarily handicaps the method of
agreement the method of difference for
mill is unaffected since the negative
instance of removing the cause still
facilitates distinguishing situations
with a plurality of causes and then the
no mixing of effects is what he calls
the intermixture of effects and that's
exemplified by the joint operation of
different forces in mechanics the
separate effects of all the causes
continued to be produced but are
compounded with one another and
disappear in one total and so I hope you
can start to glimmer and see that this
last situation is something like how you
put together genetic and generic causal
factors into a explanation because the
intermixture of effects obtains for that
situation
so Mill continues effects are
intermingled with and disguised by the
homogeneous and closely allied effects
of other causes they are no longer
separately discernable some of which may
cancel one another others many others do
not appear distinguish we've emerged in
one some now mill has a solution so he's
worried because in this case the method
of difference which for mill is the most
powerful method of the four and is
actually the basis for residues and
concomitant variations as well this is
the dilemma it handicaps that method you
can't just remove a cause and figure out
what's going on so he's got to give us a
solution the solution for him is the
principle of the composition of causes
if we happen to know what would be the
effect of each cause when acting
separately from the other we're often
able to arrive deductively or a priori
at a correct prediction of what will
arise from their conjunct agency well
that leaves us with a dilemma because if
that's the solution that is available to
us when we face the situation of the
intermixture of effects we can't get it
the first requisite therefore still the
laws of those tendencies but there's no
laws of genetics in the relevant sense
that mill was thinking from which we
could deductively derive those
consequences additionally we would need
to know what would be the effect of each
cause when acting separately from the
other but here we don't have the causal
isolation that we might like you can't
simply knock out a mechanical process in
the same way as one knocks out a gene so
I think mill though he was optimistic
that those laws would be discovered at
least recognized at the time that quote
the difficulty is most of all
conspicuous in the case of physiological
phenomena it being seldom possible to
separate the different agencies which
collectively compose an organized body
which is maybe a hard way of saying that
biology is difficult but the point here
being that
the strategy he's putting forward as a
way of dealing with the intermixture
facts is not a strategy that will help
us deal with the contemporary situation
of explanatory integration between
generic and genetic causes so that
brings us then to what sort of
philosophical models do we have
available to us what could we draw on
potentially to deal with this situation
so I want to talk about four this is not
an exhaustive list per se but it's just
one that's meant to cover a lot of the
standing candidates one is reductionism
where you would reduce the genetic
causes to the generic causes or reduce
the genetic explanations to generic
explanations the second strategy
apportioning causal responsibility
determining relative contributions of
different causes to an effect a position
called integrative pluralism
synthesizing multiple idealized single
factor models of operating causes and an
approach that I'm putting in mank I'm
putting this in quotations on purpose
because this is meant to flag a
particular philosophical approach not
just the language of mechanisms or
generally where a single mechanism
description containing multiple causal
factors and displaying productive
continuity among component part
interactions is another possible model
okay so I don't want to dwell on any of
these at too much length largely they're
not adequate for a variety of reasons
and I just want to flag those so let me
try and run through those in order so
reductionism isn't going to work in part
because we've already seen that both
types of causation are affirmed there's
no attempt or interest in reducing
genetics to physics among the
practitioners in fact genetics if
anything has preeminence so if you
propose that it was going to be the
reduction of the genetic to the generic
they would I think be no traction
because the genetic is the one that has
the experimental and community dominance
in terms of the epistemology
additionally existing models of
reductionism concentrate on reducing
anatomical or organismal to the
molecular
to the generic or physical so that's not
even what some of the projects are
engaged in doing they're focused on
saying how can we bring the organismal
level or a tissue level or something
down to a genetic molecular level not a
physical force level or something like
that most importantly though from from
where I sit in trying to understand what
the scientists are up to here is what i
call the symmetry of causal
responsibility which i think is well
captured in this quote from french
researcher working at this juncture
during early development embryos undergo
morfa genetic movements that give rise
to the physical shape of the organism
these movements which begin at
gastrulation are under the control of
the developmental gene expression
cascade here it is shown that the
reverse is also true namely that gene
expression can be modulated by the
mechanical effects of the Morpho genetic
movements of the embryo early
developmental gene expression can be
modulated because of exogenously and
endogenously induced mechanical strains
making the biochemical patterning of the
embryo sensitive to the physical shape
of the embryo and so it's this ability
to reverse the order of causation that
one can cause the other and that that's
part of what is interesting about this
explanatory integration is how then do
you make sense of it when you can't
privilege one or the other that often
times it's a matter of where you start
which one initiates a sequence second
approach apportioning calls a
responsibility actually isn't going to
work because in essence it's a following
of Mills composition of cause causes
principle so this has been discussed in
contemporary context by Elliot sober so
physical forces are going to obey the
principle because one can answer the
relevant counterfactual questions so if
you say is this particles acceleration
due more to gravity or to electricity
then the question need to answer is what
would they do if the other force was
absent right and then that lets you
account for the relative contribution of
the different forces but if we were to
do the same thing for development it
starts to get puzzling what it
mean for genes the environment to obey
the composition of causes principle the
question is problematic what would they
do if the other was absent so what would
the genes do if there was no environment
you know it's puzzling question because
in a sense it's not something that we
can assess in the same way that you can
case of physical forces there's no
common currency available to measure
those contributions no particular kinds
of units at best which you can get is
and this is not that it's bad it's quite
good when you can get it an ordinal
ranking of factors that account for
variation of population by a variety of
techniques sober I think encapsulated it
nicely said for it to make sense to ask
what are how much a cause contributes to
an effect the various causes must be
commenced herbal in the way they produce
their their effects and that commencer
ability is exactly what is not present
in this case alright so the third model
is integrative pluralism this was put
forward by Sandra Mitchell it's supposed
to be specifically tailored to cases of
complex phenomena whose features are the
result of multiple causes and you've got
a two-step procedure first formulate
idealize models where a particular
causal factor operates in isolation what
she refers to his theoretical modeling
and then you integrate these idealized
models to explain a particular concrete
phenomenon so this is a pictorial
representation that she offers you start
with an ideal world where only one
factor is operating like genetic
diversity and then you create a model
and then you create as many models as
represent the different things that you
are idealizing and then somehow those
get integrated into a common package to
explain the actual concrete phenomena
but I don't think this works for a
variety of reasons one is that the
idealized models pick out different
causes of the same genus so integration
relates causal factor species of the
same genus what you've basically got
there is an implicit common currency
assumption exactly what we just
identified we don't have an or in this
case and it's not clear how idealize
models that pick out causal factor
different types can be integrated there
are other questions about how this model
works I'm not going to focus on those
but this is just those that are relevant
to this particular case it also assumes
that models describe only what would
happen in non-overlapping ideal world
but the overlap is unavoidable this is
basically an assumption of the separable
ax t of causes the very kind of thing
that we said we don't have in this
circumstance additionally the genetic
causal reasoning in developmental
biology does not involve formulating
idealized theoretical models of the kind
that Mitchell was arguing for in the
case that she was putting forward so
there's multiple problems for whether it
can help us in this current situation
the last one is the most subtle
mechanisms because in some respects it
has the most promise for what we need to
do but there's several reasons why it
won't do as well one is differing
measurements of time the ordering of
events are measured within a mechanism
on this approach intervals from set up
determination are stages within the
operation of the mechanism but that
differs from developmental time which is
measured with external standardized
periodization so stages are not keyed to
particular mechanisms that's important
because stages facilitate the study of
different kinds of developmental
mechanisms with different characteristic
rates and durations within a common
framework so the same concern molecular
mechanisms can be studied in different
species because the corresponding
mechanism description is not anchored to
the temporal sequence found in a model
organism periodization additionally
there are bottoming out assumptions
mechanism descriptions are supposed to
bottom out in lowest level mechanisms in
molecular biology and molecular
neurobiology hierarchies of mechanisms
bottom out in descriptions of the
activities of macromolecules smaller
molecules and ions but this actually
militates against describing the
reciprocal interplay that symmetry of
causal responsibility in the explanatory
in degree
that we're interested in there's not a
single appropriate level of explanation
they are inherently multi-level
additionally these explanations
concentrate on composition rather than
causation they focus on that
organization of the components their
constitutive explanations they explain
the behavior of the mechanism as a whole
in terms of the organized activities
interactions of its components but
mechanisms are often embedded in
different contexts where they're
hierarchical organization differs
there's lots of examples here you can
just take one cardio Genesis and all
metazoans investigated thus far depends
on a cascade of expression involving NK
x 2.5 the homeobox gene also called
tinman but these mechanisms are embedded
very differently drosophila has an open
vascular system no a trio of ventricle
chamber morphology which means that the
role of fluid forces in the formation of
the heart differed dramatically from
those invertebrate species such as
zebrafish so the reciprocal interplay
between genetic and physical causation
is not conserved precisely because these
compositional differences in mechanisms
alter the relationships of physical
causation that means the ability to
generate integrated explanations is lost
in the mechanism descriptions that
abstract away from those precise
contexts okay well that obviously then
means we need something more than those
existing philosophical models and I'm
going to now try and say something about
a perspective that I've been developing
to try and think about explanatory
integration in these contexts in
development first one to highlight the
perspective I'm working out of is one
that some of you may be familiar with
where you think about causal explanation
in the sciences as focusing on causes as
difference makers that language itself
might not be familiar but the
methodology is pretty standard practice
a causal explanation is one that cites
variables representing causes in which
manipulating the values for the
variables makes a uniform
but still possibly probabilistic
difference in weather and outcome
obtains in particular controlled
contexts for shorthand counterfactual
dependencies it's a widespread
strategies used all over the place in
the sciences it's got lots of advantages
the ability to presume contextual
factors as a part of the standardized
explanatory background you're not you
don't have to explain all the context
you just have to hold the context fixed
and then see what happens when you
change different values for variables
you have an emphasis on controls so this
is very much a causal reasoning that is
about experimental manipulation and also
the capacity to recognize more than one
cause contributing to an effect to
identify difference maker is not to
identify the only one there can be more
than one depending on the circumstances
so what I want to do is add a little bit
to this discussion of difference making
with a concept that ken waters has
called actual difference makers and what
this does is simply draws a few
distinctions when we talk about
difference makers so that we can
identify potential difference makers a
causal variable whose manipulation could
make a uniform difference and whether an
outcome obtains the actual difference
maker as the causal very booze
manipulation makes a uniform difference
and then an actual difference maker a
causal variable whose manipulation makes
a uniform difference right so the
important distinction there between
potential and actual and then the
definite article versus the indefinite
article where we're trying to understand
whether or not there's only one actual
difference maker but this distinction is
important because I think in the daily
business of experimental biology what
you have is the identification of actual
difference makers and model organisms
they're the targets of manipulations
undertaken in laboratory investigation
there are lots of things that are
possible difference makers that are
often times completely ignored okay and
so that's why paying attention to actual
difference makers
quite important for understanding that
the value of the variable must actually
differ and this variation must bring
about the actual differences among the
entities in the population this can be
done with different types of difference
makers including genetic and generic
causes and it transcends the
experimental manipulation dis analogies
that is you don't have to only identify
something through a genetic knockout to
be able to treat it as a difference
maker you can treat physical phenomena
in terms of difference makers as well
it's applicable to different kinds of
intervention techniques so the
integrative expedit expectation can be
understood in terms of finding actual
difference makers rather than the actual
difference maker because of course we
have more than one the whole point is
integrating combined and so what we're
saying is can we think about how to
bring together actual difference makers
that are genetic with actual difference
makers that are generic and that brings
us to a sort of template for how we
might do that in one more bit from mill
and mills to idealize ations that we
looked at earlier were explicit he
acknowledged them he said I made these
assumptions when I laid out these rules
of reasoning but there were some
embedded in there that were not and the
implicit one that I want to draw
attention to is that the mediating
process between cause and effect is
treated as irrelevant there isn't it's
just simply not a part of the discussion
and yet that trajectory from cause to
effect is critical because in
investigating situations with a
plurality of causes intermixture effects
it's precisely that trajectory where
different kinds of causes might become
relevant to the effect at the end so we
take that in mind we say well what
happens if we then think about that
mediating process of the temporality of
the situation that brings the me to the
core idea of what I want to highlight in
my new model which is that you combine
or juxtapose genetic and generic actual
difference makers in a temporary ordered
sequence defined by
an explicit periodization so relations
of systemic dependence between genetic
and physical causation can be keyed to
different aspects of the temporal period
during which the mediation of cause and
effect occurs that's the basic idea to
try and unpack that a little bit more so
I'm calling it temporal sequence
juxtaposition just for shorthand notice
that embedded in the assumptions we
don't have a common currency which you
needed to do a portion and causal
responsibility we're treating causes as
difference makers against standardized
backgrounds and we're looking at actual
difference makers where more than one
can have an effect and then we're
combining those within a period ization
and the periodization can be thought of
as temporal organization right so not
spatial organization but temporal
organization it's not giving us overall
magnitudes but it is telling us what's
happening by virtue of a joint effect so
the factors are explicitly represented
within a period ization the factors are
placed in sequential order beyond simply
the cause occurred earlier later and
there's juxtaposition the physical force
factors and genetic factors are placed
next to one another in different stages
but not superimposed onto a single stage
temporal stage in this case now
abstractly what that could look like is
this and this is more not something that
I think you would see in a scientific
practice but just a way of trying to
articulate it so that you have here sets
of potential difference makers right
that are physical and genetic right and
of those physical and genetic difference
makers right then what we can look at is
which one's of those are actual and then
when we identify the actual ones the
ordering of them into a sequence so the
actual difference maker g1 the actual
difference maker p3 the actual
difference maker g5 leading to some sort
of
phenotypic reserves what are the so the
differences are make you mean this
difference what is this right so the
difference is that the difference making
is keyed to the the next step in the
sequence so I'll the next slide will
make that more apparent because I think
this is the abstraction here is not as
helpful here is an example I think that
helps to tease that out where you see
this sort of reasoning in a case of
development where you tease out
difference in nodal expression leads to
a difference in pit x2 expression which
leads to a difference in the spiral
structure of the outflow tract and so on
and as you walk through now we shift to
a different set of factors these are
this is a physical flow of the fluid of
blood and then now we'll go back to the
way those differences make a difference
in the genetic factors and then finally
we get to the outcome which is the
developmental phenomena the left-sided
aortic arch so that i don't know if that
addresses all of the question but
hopefully get the where the difference
makes a difference it was with respect
to the steps in the sequence and of
course the point here is to highlight
that the the kind of strategy that I'm
talking about is not something that is
somehow only generated in my head up
taking cues from the ways in which it
seems like there has been successful
approaches to this in a few cases
already in the sciences now stepping
back for a minute we don't get strict
composition of causes here in the way
that mill would have wanted no overall
sum of relative contributions but what
we do get as an understanding of how
multiple causes can be combined to yield
a correct correct prediction of what
will arise from their conscious
agency which is what he was requesting
so it the model is explicitly addressing
the intermixture of effects the dilemma
that was set out for the situation in
the first place more broadly we can
think about this model fulfilling a
variety of criteria of adequacy that
were extracted along the way when we
were talking about alternative models we
got a middle way between the composition
of causes and the inability to provide
any substantive unity when ranking
difference makers it's specifiable from
experimental interventions because each
of those that's the way each of those
actual difference makers gets
established and it displays combination
or integration in the sense that the
reciprocal interplay that is of interest
is literally delineated it's not
reductionist in the sense of privilege
ngmoco zation over the other you've got
equal validity of the modes the cemetry
we talked about within the explicit
periodization so not just that X causes
Y but when there's descriptive
correspondence with forms of reasoning
displayed by the scientists it overcomes
some of the experimental manipulation
dis analogies that were a concern and it
recovers the emphasis on productive
continuity and mechanism description
approaches but without the accompanying
problems that we identified okay here's
a caveat and a small joke some of you
already are trying to figure out what is
he doing so this is what I call avoiding
the sour on stance for Lord of the Rings
fans this is not one ring to rule them
all it's one model of explanatory
integration others are possible and are
needed so the point of this project is
not to say that this is the silver
bullet that handles all the cases
perfectly instead what it is is a model
that handles some of these cases and
seems to get over the problems that the
other models had
but that there's going to be other
situations where we're going to need
further models so not all causal
relations can be represented in terms of
linear ordering and certain cases going
a lot model feedback and things like
that and so the point is just to say we
shouldn't expect any one of these models
to necessarily comprehensively give us
everything all at once you don't want to
be the bad guy right that's the way of
putting it so let me now then say a few
words about the consequences and and
then finish there's a trade-off inherent
in this approach because the consequence
of the model for combining genetic and
physical causation and explanations of
embryogenesis is a narrowing of the
scope of generalizations ascertained for
the modes of causation and isolation
increased explanatory integration is
purchased at the cost of decreased
generalization okay let me try and say
why that is the case so first the
reciprocal interplay between genetic and
physical causation is not conserved
precisely because compositional
differences in mechanisms alter
relationships of physical causation we
highlighted that earlier this is
something that the researchers
themselves have recognized there are no
one to one correspondence principles
between gene functions and the
mechanical events that they affect it is
clear that mechanical processes have a
polygenic origin and that dozens if not
hundreds of genes are responsible for
physical processes operating on a range
of scales from molecular to cellular to
the tissue level now there's one
interesting possible exception though I
think it's maybe the exception that
proves the rule a recent paper
identified possible conservation of
early mesoderm specification at
gastrulation via a mechanotransduction
pathway what's fascinating about that
particular case is that it shows exactly
how you can get diversity of physical
processes while maintaining a particular
mechanotransduction pathway so in some
sense it
illustrates the point about why you're
not able to get the generalization with
respect to the physical forces so second
reason is that the periodization is used
to assign responsibilities to genetic
and physical difference makers are
specific to the model taxa used in
experimentation the basis for the
explanatory integration that's being
used is local not global okay in the
sense that those are local to the
particular model organisms that are
being used and in fact multiple
periodization oftentimes are used within
that context so mill had claimed that a
deductive method is required to address
the intermixture of effects if possible
it would secure the expected generality
since it is obtained after the general
laws are discovered from this one can
calculate the joint effect a priori
that's not something that we're in a
position to do and so we're either
prevented from addressing that
intermixture or we must adopt an
alternative strategy and so what I've
been trying to do is offer at least one
way of getting another strategy that
will address that particular problem now
why this is important to think about the
trade-off is because a key rationale for
the use of model organisms in
developmental investigation is the
existence of conserved genetic
mechanisms we study flies in frogs as
examples for the development of animals
in general nothing surprising here even
though it was surprising through much of
the time that it was discovered that
deep similarities and the mechanisms
underlying developmental processes are
across a wide range of bilaterally
symmetric metazoans these comparisons
have defined a common core of genetic
pathways guiding development and those
common core of pathways if you can study
them in a fruit fly then it means that
what you've learned about them in a
fruit fly will tell you something about
the species that you're not studying if
these are shared core genetic pathways
so the trade-offs involved in achieving
the kind of explanatory integration we
talked about today may actually
discourage attempts at pursuing it this
exacerbates the problem of the modeling
commencer ability that we described
earlier and notably
any of the explanatory integration
attempts come from what is here the
minority perspective that is the
biomechanics and generic explanations
there is not equal clamoring for
explanatory integration and those who
are more invested in the model organism
platforms that would be at issue here
are the ones that are more potentially
resistant to it okay so let me just
summarize and enclose so an increasing
recognition of the reciprocal interplay
of genetic engineering causes is
accompanied by an aim of explanatory
integration that explanatory integration
faces problems arising from modeling
commencer ability manipulation dis
analogies and the intermixture of
affects many extant philosophical miles
of integration are not adequate for the
task of explicate explanatory
integration of the genetic and generic
the temporal sequence juxtaposition of
actual difference makers is one model
that does and directly addresses the
stated problems but the resulting
trade-off between integration and
generality suggests that explanatory
integration of this kind will face
resistance or potentially be deferred
now let me give the final word to trink
all another for those who knew I mean
he'd like to find a word he says I and
this is in his autobiography was
published at the year of his death I
find the most satisfying biological
research to be the kind that integrates
information from multiple levels into a
coherent explanatory picture what a
pleasure it is to be able to piece
together molecular cytological and
behavioral results into a comprehensive
understanding of a complex biological
phenomenon the real issue may be whether
my work can yet be connected to any or
all of the new discoveries and molecular
biology neither I nor they have been
very successful in connecting the
mechanical aspects of embryonic
development to their molecular aspects
so within a decade of drinks death i
think these connections are emerging but
the challenges of integration require
explicit attention to the epistemology
of causal reasoning
involved in explaining development and
hopefully at least some of what I've
articulated today takes us in that
necessary direction with that I will say
stop stop say thanks okay write history
as a difference maker this is still
quite experimental and that might be
another incommensurate process but yes
but that's one of the things that
explicitly in an Evo Devo many people
would be right so one of the dimensions
of this particular project is to really
understand how historical Sciences in
particular deal with this sort of
situation because one of the
difficulties with historical Sciences is
sometimes sorting out possible
difference makers from actual difference
makers and so in the future work that
I'm looking at trying to look at what
kinds of methodologies allow you to sort
through historical causes in such a way
that you can make determinations of
actual difference makers and some of
what I think that involves is a
recognition that especially the generic
explanatory approaches require a degree
of simulation and theoretical modeling
that is not always accepted as
legitimate by standard genetic paradigms
in biology and so some of the some of
the extension of this sort of approach
is in sorting through
more so than I can do here because this
is all kind of experimental biology in
some respects maybe this is the easier
case because of that trying to then
figure out how you would make those
sorts of claims and if you're interested
I have one place where I've tried to do
this is there's been some discussion
about whether or not the Cambrian
explosion can be explained in terms of
physical forces being more predominant
in the early stages of that particular
historical event and what I have
identified at least in that case in
collaboration with a paleobiologist is
that there's some real epistemological
hurdles to being able to make those
claims but at the same time they have
largely not been fought through that
explicitly yet and and the people who
are engaged in it I think especially on
this project that I'm in over the next
few years I'm hoping that we can bring
in historical causes because I think
you're right they are a hard case but we
want to for this sort of endeavor
so I'm just wondering you touched a
little bit about systems biology and
we're increasingly as biologists
thinking about you know systems this you
know integrated parts and you couch your
explanation in terms of the sort of
temporal linearity of development and
I'm wondering when you don't have that
obvious sort of temporal linearity and
you have potentially a lot of
interacting parts whether either this
framework or even sort of difference
makers in general you know using that
causation it still retains its you know
usefulness yeah good so I mean it one of
the things that I didn't highlight in
talking about the possibility of other
models was that those other models would
invoke different ways of thinking about
causal structure I mean I talked about
representing causal relations as
difference makers but you might have
other ways of doing that so I don't
think that a single particular approach
is going to capture everything we want
to know about these systems and so what
we then need to do is ask ourselves do
we have in the the toolkit of resources
ways of conceptualizing causes and tools
available to us to capture these sorts
of relations and that yes the the sort
of linear sequence description that I'm
highlighting here is attractive in some
areas of developmental biology but in
others it's not going to be the best way
to go and I think that the what it will
require and it and this is not something
I talked about here is more explicit
attention attention to the ways in which
these different approaches abstract and
idealize in different ways so
abstraction in the sense of the things
that you omit from your causal model and
idealize in the sense of things that you
put into the causal model that you know
are technically wrong all right the
classic frictionless surfaces or
something like that and the degree to
which the specific abstractions and
idealization that we use in the models
can be
made explicit I think is the degree to
which we can have a better understanding
of whether the kinds of models that we
are using are really capturing the space
of possibilities for these causal
relations that we want them to the but
the stance is clearly one where one
particular approach for sure isn't going
to do it how many we will need is going
to be part of the empirical work and I
think right now what is exciting is that
one of those areas is precisely what
you're seeing in the modeling and
systems biology I really enjoyed it
doesn't oh it's for the recorder no I
really enjoyed this but I think there
are two things that troubled me a little
bit okay so the first is just a comment
really which is you started out with
mechanics in the role of mechanics and
really it's it's it's only over the last
you know decade or two that people have
really been able to connect mechanics as
well as they have to two molecules
themselves you know how does a how does
a biological molecule do work you know
how does it convert chemical energy into
into mechanical energy and that's it's
particularly exciting time now because
we know how to measure it and we're
seeing in different systems and things
like that so the the second thing is is
that as I listened to your description
of generic and genetic causes it's very
appealing i kept mapping your statements
on to my own work Oh over and over again
but but but by the end I realized that
that this this division while it's
useful to think about I'm wondering
whether it's really taking place that is
that is problems are solved and we think
about things that you know in that are
going on inside cells we're always
reaching to a genetic adanaii using your
terminology a generic and a genetic
explanation we worry about you know
diffusion across the cell we worry about
the density that that molecules have to
operate inside a cell that a membrane is
a block these generic explanations or
these generic contributors are always
there there's always an interplay and so
I'm wondering whether this division
what is this division really doing for
us as we try to you know make our models
I feel like we're already using both
pieces of the puzzle to excel in our
work good so I mean one of the things
that you're describing their I think
that's important is that there are
certain ways in which simply following
out how something works involves you in
a combining of the genetic in the
generic because part of getting to the
bottom of what's going on you you look
at those sorts of properties what I
think those important is that it's not
the case that that strategy captures all
of what is encapsulated under generic
and so the path that you described just
now involved looking at properties of
the molecules and then asking how those
behave within the cellular context and
the physical principles that those work
by our generic because other entities
work according to those principles and
not necessarily in living systems but
that's not exhaustive of the kind of
generic properties that you might want
to consider in looking at the system and
so especially in the the cases that we
have been looking at here in development
the issue about large-scale geometrical
effects between tissue folding and
things like that are one of the key
concerns so the way in which say
gastrulation certain tissue movements
and stretching and bending initiate
these mechanotransduction events and to
me I think it's still valuable to pay
attention to the distinction between
genetic engineering because just by
following out a certain causal chain
that is of interest doesn't initiate you
into all of the potential things that
you might want to eventually focus on
and so the genetic and the generic is a
way of capturing those and reminding
especially a lot of developmental
geneticists
are working that it's not enough to just
say oh yeah there's the physics of the
embryo and let me get back to another
mutant screen where I've identified more
of the genetic difference makers and so
I guess part of that message is to say
that not all researchers work the same
way and so some of the virtuous
tendencies that you're describing about
following out are not done by everybody
and it's not because some people are
good scientists and other people are not
good scientist is just certain
tendencies and how research is
accomplished and so I think the genetic
generic distinction retains a usefulness
in drawing attention to those sorts of
patterns which differ across various
research communities though I can
understand that with respect to
potentially an individual research
project it might feel like that
distinction doesn't do get you as much
traction so maybe there's a where you're
standing and looking so one aspect of
your model that makes it work is that
you have a linear and temporal sequence
right and the other temporal sequences
like behave all sequences if you thought
about whether you can apply the same
model of explanation of difference
makers in stages to behavior sequences I
have not spent time thinking about that
but that sort of direction is certainly
appealing to me and the hope is that the
model has that capacity to be developed
for further contexts of those sorts of
kinds I think that part of why this
project interests me is because I think
that this genetic generic
combining oftentimes is occurring across
disciplinary boundaries where the
reasoning that is engaging the or that
the scientists are engaged in is is
different and therefore genetic generic
there was you know internal external yes
causation you know that's right so so
you can think about ways in which if you
partition modes of causation differently
you can find that you have similar sorts
of questions about whether people focus
more on one or the other and what would
be involved in bringing the two together
and that actually in many cases I think
you will find that the reason why
research communities tend to focus on
one or the other was because actually
bringing them together is not trivial
it's not obvious and takes this sort of
explicit type of consideration about
what how you're thinking about the
causes and and the like but yeah that's
that's that's another way of stepping
out of this and saying it's not just
genetic engineering but the very idea of
thinking about causes differently in
different communities of research and
then asking now we come together how do
we come together in a productive way and
not just run in parallel thank you very
much please joy stairs
you